For this course we've provided a web app
that has a build script to compile it,
and some tests to run.
In order to run this app, your server
will need to have a particular version
of node.js, and additional packages to
be able to build and run the tests.
Without some automation
to make this faster,
it would take an unreasonable
amount of time to install it on
each development system and production
server you might have, this is why we've
decided to create a golden image,
we'll use Packer to do that.
Packer can create golden images for
different build targets, for
example, VirtualBox and VMware, for
use on your workstation, and also for
cloud providers,
like Google Compute Engine, Amazon AWS,
DigitalOcean, and Microsoft Azure.
So you can run the exact same
operating system, libraries, and
everything else no matter where
you might be deploying your app.
Once this image is built, you'll
be able to use Vagrant to bring up
a virtual machine on your own computer
from that image, share a folder with it,
connect to it, see the app running, and
then change the app if you wish,
then build and run tests on it.
First, let's talk more about Packer,
how does it work?